[Musique]
bonsoir à tout
bonsoir à tous alors ce soir un grand
défi un grand défi nous rassemble je
dois en 18 minutes vous expliquer non
pas à quoi servent les mathématiques
à quoi sert le calcul mais à quoi sert
l'éducation aux mathématiques alors pour
ça je vais commencer par quelques
chiffres les mathématiques est ce que
vous savez que on dépense 8 milliard
d'euros par an pour éduquer les français
aux mathématiques 8 milliards et
beaucoup beaucoup et pourtant quand on
interroge les jeunes par exemple combien
vaut 35 de poissons et bien la moitié
des jeunes qui sortent de cm2 ne savent
pas faire cette multiplication
alors je vais pas vous poser ce soir la
question combien font 35 deux fois 100
on a demandé aux jeunes qui arrivent en
sixième
combien vaut un quart eh bien vous savez
quelle est la réponse la plus fréquente
qu'on reçoit un quart égale 1,2 alors il
vous est arrivé parfois d'aller dans des
soirées de discuter avec des amis
et puis quand on commence à parler
chiffres tout ça il ya quelque chose
qu'il faut vraiment vraiment pas abordés
c'est la question des pourcentages
non les pourcentages
oh la la la la la la ça fait mal alors
là on a les trois majeurs difficultés de
l'éducation au calcul alors ce soir nous
avons déclaré les mathématiques grande
cause nationale et nous allons guérir
tous ensemble et je vais essayer de vous
montrer que les mathématiques ce n'est
pas uniquement le calcul mais c'est
autre chose
et pour ça je vais vous raconter
plusieurs histoires la première histoire
se passe pendant l'assaut
seconde guerre mondiale une histoire
dramatique une histoire de héros une
histoire de guerrier vous voyez sur
cette photo n'a un avion américain qui
vient de se faire canarder par des
mitraillettes japonaise terrible gi's
est revenu au bercail
heureusement alors les nos généraux
américains se demander comment nous
allons faire pour sauver nos pilotes de
cette vilaine mitraillette japonais va
se passer dans le pacifique pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale alors on a fait
des études ou est-ce que les balles des
japonais arrivent sur nos avions alors
vous avez ici
des exemples alors les jeunes aux
généraux américains ssii bas c'est
simple on va protéger la carlingue de
nos avions on va mettre du blindage
supplémentaire à ces endroits là et tant
pis pour les japonais quand même y avait
un gars un général qui s'est dit mais
peut-être pourrait demander un
mathématicien par exemple ce qu'est ce
qu'ils en pensaient un gars qui avait
été éduqués aux mathématiques et sont
allés voir ce monsieur abraham white un
statisticien célèbre et abraham oil
s'est dit non pour pas blindés aux
endroits où vous voyez des points rouges
au contraire il faut blinder les avions
aux endroits vous ne voyez pas de bain
rouge et pourquoi
tout simplement parce que les avions qui
ont été touchés par exemple sur un
moteur bien ils sont pas rentrés au
bercail
vous les avez pas vu tout simplement et
alors
donc c'était exactement le contraire
qu'il fallait faire heureusement que
habré wild a avait pensé ces choses là
alors la première leçon qu'on va
apprendre ce soir tous ensemble c'est
que les mathématiques apprennent à nous
méfier des évidences et à nous poser la
question du pourquoi et du potet du
pourquoi pas la deuxième histoire que je
vais vous raconter une histoire un peu
étrange de même dire cela c'est un
original
je vais me poser la question combien de
pâtes faux
il pour avancer qu'est ce que ça a à
voir avec les maths alors regardons un
petit peu ce qui se passe dans la nature
on a des animaux à deux pattes à quatre
pattes à six pattes à huit pattes et on
a même des animaux à 1000 pacte alors ok
les animaux c'est bien mais nous on est
peut-être plus que ça et puis on arrive
à fabriquer des choses qu'on arrive à
avancer et puis on est au 21ème siècle
et combien de roues faut-il pour avancer
alors des gens qui aiment bien une seule
roue il ya des gens qui aiment bien le
deux roues
il ya des gens qui aiment bien leucate
où certains préfèrent même le 6 roues et
d'autre le virouil et puis il ya même
des gens qui préfèrent le 132 roues pour
transporter des grosses machines que
l'être humain fabrique et qu'est-ce que
ça à voir avec les mathématiques mais
moi j'ai remarqué que les humain vph est
aussi d engin à trois roues tient
étrange pourquoi les animaux
il n'ya pas d'animaux avec trois pattes
vous avez une réponse à cette question
pourquoi il n'ya pas d'animaux avec
trois pattes
alors moi je suis allé voir des
biologistes serait posé la question
comment ça se fait que dans la nature
voit pas d'animaux à trois pattes alors
qu'il ya des vélo à trois roues et que
trois c'est bien mais stable on avance
bien
d'ailleurs les enfants y arrive et de
fil en aiguille on s'est même demandé
pourquoi et comment les pattes venait au
serpent alors là c'était extraordinaire
et puis il ya des gens comme ça des
mathématiciens des biologistes pour
commencer à se poser ce genre de drôles
de questions
et puis ils ont écrit des livres cet
excellent livre par exemple comment les
battre viennent au serpent c'est toute
une histoire autour de la plasticité du
vivant comment expliquer que le vivant
et plastiques comment les phénomènes
d'émergence se comprennent
grâce aux mathématiques et cette
collaboration entre les mathématiques et
la biologie
c'est ce que vous voyez là est en
quelque sorte une explication une
mobilisation pour expliquer pourquoi les
taches viennent aux léopards et plus
sérieusement
ou comment on va pouvoir guérir des
maladies grâce aux mathématiques et à la
modélisation
donc c'est une chose assez sérieuse et
la leçon numéro deux que je retiens de
cette histoire c'est tout simplement que
les mathématiques nous amène une pause
et de parfois des questions complètement
absurde mais qui font avancer la science
ma troisième histoire une histoire un
peu plus marrante et l'histoire des
statistiques
winston churchill disait moi je me méfie
des statistiques de ne comprend que les
statistiques que j'ai fait moi-même et
un grand homme politique disait une
vérité est un mensonge qui a longtemps
servi cet homme c'est edouard herriot un
petit dione vous le connaissez bien
alors moi j'aime bien cette même bien
cette phrase d'edouard herriot
alors regardons ensemble si vous voulez
bien
cette courbe c'est grâce vous en avez
tous les jours à la télé dans les
journaux dans les magazines
on vous explique comment ça se passe
tiens donc
cette étrange 1 là je vois la
consommation de crème sure c'est la
crème ac est grand en france lancé
canadien et puis je vois que quand même
c'est bizarre le taux d'homicide suis
étrangement la cour bord de la
consommation de crem
tiens donc cette étrange c'est tellement
étrange que peut-être qu'il y aurait une
relation entre les deux peut-être même
que ceux qui mangent de la crème
pourraient devenir des meurtriers non
moi même qu'on pourrait faire des études
étrange vous avez déjà vu des corps
comme ça c'est tous les jours
et puis vous avez des comptes comme
celle là encore plus frappante
il nous explique que tout ça c'est dû au
pétrole
la collision entre deux les trains les
voitures au canada a quelque chose à
voir avec les puits de pétrole en arabie
saoudite 1 112 tonnes mouais moi je vous
dis qu'il ya quelque chose à
et en fait à qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe
ne vous faites pas voir s'il vous plaît
ce soir avec ses courbes ses courbes de
tendance qui se suivent trop bout de
près soyez critique regarder un petit
peu peut-être qu'il ya on a superposé en
trichant un petit peu on entend les
données erronées et bien la leçon numéro
3 que je nous allons retenir ce soir
c'est que les mathématiques servent à
développer le sens critique et surtout
ne pas confondre corrélation et
causalité deux phénomènes corps et les
bons peuvent avoir des courbes qui vont
se suivre mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ya une causalité la quatrième histoire
que je vais vous raconter ce soir c'est
une histoire étrange histoire un peu
anciennes qui vient du 19e siècle
moi je me demande si vraiment les jeunes
il ya beaucoup de jeunes ce soir dans la
salle lever la main ouais
applaudissaient voilà très bien moi on
me dit les jeunes ils sont de plus en
plus grands c'est pas dit de plus en
plus intelligents un de plus en plus
grands mais c'est vrai c'est ça alors
écoutez on va faire un bot
si vous voulez bien vous proposer deux
assertions la première assertion dit que
quand les parents sont grands les
enfants sont encore plus grands la
deuxième assertion cbc quand les parents
sont grands les enfances ans tendance
est un peu plus petit que les parents
alors voyons voir qui est ce qu'ils
votent pour lever la main ok pièce qui
votent pour b a pas terrible et bien
c'est francis galton qui a donné la
réponse en 1869 la réponse était bon
alors comment francis galton a fait ça
en six galton a d'abord cherché des
données il a mesuré 984 enfants qu'ils
étaient devenus adultes
il a mesuré les parents aussi il a fait
un grand tableau il a fait il a mis sur
x la taille des haies des parents il a
levé un petit dessin comme ça où il a
mis tout l'ensemble l'ensemble de la
situation et est ce qu'il a fait il a
remarqué que ces points avaient l'air de
se se retrouver autour d'une ellipse
et puis il a il a fait quelques calculs
et puis il est apparu que si les parents
avaient la même taille que les enfants
alors normalement ça devait la tendance
devait suivre cette courbe qui est une
droite gauche
or les données suivent la courbe bleue
et voyelles et un tout petit peu en
dessous de la courbe rouge ça veut dire
que quand les parents sont grands les
enfants sont un peu plus petit et
surtout que quand les parents sont
petits les enfants sont un peu plus
grand alors je vous rassure ça marche ça
marche aussi dans plein d'autres choses
notamment l'intelligence et les
mathématiques vous donne même une
formule on va passer sur cette formule
un peu trop compliqué alors qu'est ce
que l'étude de françois de francis
galton as nous apprend c'est que les
enfants sont un peu plus petits que les
parents quand les parents sont grands
c'est ce qu'on appelle la régression à
la moyenne alors la leçon numéro 4 ça
sera que les mathématiques permettent
d'établir des vérités qui sont loin
d'être évidente
et il faut travailler alors la cinquième
histoire une histoire on se dit il faut
je vais vous dire il faut se méfier de
la proportionnalité
alors on va faire un petit quiz je vous
sens chaud un bébé de trois mois pèse 6
kg c'est vrai combien pèsera-t-il à 6
mois à 12 mois est à 24 mois
les parents vous n'avez pas le droit de
répondre uniquement les jeunes à la 11e'
et bas à 3 mois 6 kg à 6 mois au bon
peut-être 12 à 12 mois 24 à 24 48 alors
ok ok vous l'avez compris non les vrais
chiffres c'est son seul à 8 kg 4 10 kg
et 12 kilos à 24 mois heureusement alors
ça c'est la proportionnalité il faut
s'en méfier on va refaire ensemble
petite expérience vous allez voir c'est
marrant vous voyez
c'est bientôt l'apéro on a quelques
coups pas de côte roannaise ici c'est un
petit peu de champagne consommer
toujours avec modération seillier et
raisonnable j'ai rempli mes coupes aux
deux tiers d'accord et je me pose la
question combien de coupe je peux verser
dans la dernière alors à votre avis
est-ce que je peux verser une coup deux
coupes 3 coupes ou quatre coupes
peut-être même 5
à votre avis est-ce qu'ils votent pour
un ps qui vote pour deux pièces qui
votent pour 3 attention il reste plus
beaucoup de coupes
mais est-ce qu'ils votent pour 4 ha ok
alors eh bien c'est entre 2 et 3 pas
évident à voir avec l'oeil et les
mathématiques vous dis c'est exactement
2,375 étrange vous avez courage à faire
cette expérience chez vous tout à
l'heure alors maintenant pire si je
remplis les coupes à moitié et que
j'essaye de verser quelques coupes dans
la dernière à votre avis combien de
coupe vous combien oui vous là au
premier rang 4 à et vous une cet homme
impressionnant
finalement quand les coupes sont remplis
à 2/3 2004 quand les coupes sont remplis
à moitié ces sept
et bien voilà c'est là la leçon la
cinquième leçon de cette histoire de ce
soir l'éducation aux calculs nous
apprend à maîtriser la multiplication et
ce et nous permet de penser au delà de
l'addition c'est à dire au delà de la
proportionnalité
alors les conclusions que je mènerai ce
soir avec vous l'éducation mathématiques
bien sûr permet de créer des esprits
libres constructif rationnelle mais
entendu mais surtout
des gens qui posent des questions qui se
posent des questions des gens qui
doutent des évidences cherche des
arguments pour atteindre peut-être
parfois et vérité des vérités complexe
mais des vérités démontrer les
emmerdeurs en finalement mais surtout
des gens qui peuvent imaginer
l'impossible les mathématiques
l'éducation aux mathématiques c'est
l'éducation à la transgression et je
terminerai par cette histoire de thomas
nüssli
il vient de mourir il ya quelques
semaines d'un tragique accident de
voiture comme anaïs lit en 1994 avait
mis le doigt sur quelque chose
d'incroyable on a appelé le bug du
pentium il faisait des calculs c'est un
match mais si elle faisait des calculs
avec un ordinateur tout neuf qui l'avait
acheté qui était muni d'un processeur
pentium ses calculs sur une constante
il s'appelait la constante de brens ses
calculs étaient fort complexe il y avait
des additions démultiplication des
divisions plein de calculs
et puis les résultats de tout ça abbey
quelque chose d'étrange et thomas était
vraiment pas content il détient assez
bizarre j'aboutis pas ma conclusion il a
refait ses calculs et l'art vérifier son
programme il a essayé sur un autre
ordinateur
tiens ça donnait pas exactement les
mêmes calculs et à la fin il s'il a
pensé l'impossible l'impossible et si
mon ordinateur se trompait vous imaginez
d'imaginer que son ordinateur c'est pas
additionner que votre calculatrice
mouvement qu'elle sait plus multiplier
et bien c'est ça que thomas a réussi à
démontrer que le processeur qu'intel la
grande compagnie intel avait fabriqué
son procès 20e avait un bug au début
intel a dit non c'est pas vrai c'est un
matheux il raconte n'importe quoi mais
en vérité thomas avait absolument raison
et intel a changé tous les processeurs
des ordinateurs c'était en 1914 l'on
raconte cette histoire dans tout
dix ans quand vous faites de
l'informatique alors voilà ma conclusion
il vous poser ce genre de question
aujourd'hui
pourquoi ne pas aimer les mathématiques
merci
[Applaudissements]